[Antani] I went to school for computer engineering in India.
I've worked with image processing, computer vision, pattern recognition, machine learning.
So, my world was filled with developing algorithms that could extract interesting
objects from imagesand videos.
Pattern Recognition is a family of techniques that looks for particular
pixel characteristics or voxel characteristics inside an image and learns to recognize thoseobjects.
Deep Learning is a way of capturing the knowledge inside an image and
encapsulating it
and then researchers like me spend time advancing
newer deep learning networks
that look more broadly into an image,
recognizing
these objects, recognizing organs in my case,
and diseases, and converting those visuals
into numerical risk predictors that could be used by clinicians.
So, my research is
currently in three very different areas. One area looks at cervical cancer.
A machine could look at the images and be a
very solid predictor of
the risk to the woman of developing cervical pre-cancer encouraging earlytreatment.
Another area I work with, Sickle Cell Disease. One of the risk factors in Sickle Cell Disease is
Cardiac Myopathy or
Cardiac Muscle Disease, which leads to stroke and perhaps even death.
Looking at cardiac echo videos and using AI to
be a solid predictor, along with other blood lab tests,
improves the chances of survival.
A third area that I'm interested in is understanding the
expression of Tuberculosis
in chest x-rays,
particularly for children and those that are HIV positive. Theexpression of disease in that sub-population
is very different from adults with TB who are not
HIV positive.
Every clinician have seen a certain number
of patients in their clinical training.
They perhaps have spent more
time at hospitals or clinical centers, and exposed to certain population,
and they become very adept
at that population.
Machines, on the other hand, could be trained on data that is free ofbias,
from different parts of the world, different
ethnicities, different age groups, so that there's
an improved care giving and therefore a
better expectation on treatment and care.